are you both doing yeah I really enjoyed
this movie and one of the things I
really dug is that it never slows down
minute it starts you are just going
you're in it you know what I mean so
talk a little bit about what was was it
did it read like that in the script that
it was just gonna be fast moving or was
only when you saw in the Edit for me it
was for me it was more so the Edit I
mean the script itself was was exciting
and just you know just felt like
reminded me of so many things that I've
been so excited and watched it grow grew
up on like Reservoir Dogs and he'd and
and things of that nature but you know
to see the cut I will say that very very
impressed with our director Bryan Kirk
you know and really never allowing the
audience to take a breather or to sit
back and relax keeps them very very
engaged and sort of you know right in it
from the jump it is relentless I just
saw it a couple days ago and the pace is
incredible really but I do like because
it takes a week plus to shoot those
shootout scenes sometimes I want to
watch those a little longer but it's
like just because I'm selfish really but
it looks amazing so you know yeah it was
a blast to shoot and Kirk was awesome
and I mean even having that dynamic with
Stefan was so important to make this
work and not make it just a cliche kind
of just action movie so I had a blast on
that's one of the things that I really
enjoyed is that your characters are not
some [ __ ] sorry language are not
like these bad guys you know it's like
there's there's dimensionality to it and
so talk a little bit about that that
it's not like good versus evil no no
it's very gray I think that's what
anchors this whole relationship
obviously Chadwick and that whole
company's in the wake of what we do so
this was everything for for me and I'm
sure I mean even signing on I'm like
okay I'm every scene with you know with
Stefan so it's like it's kind of
important who you're gonna be opposite
the whole movie now
- oh man so we had a blast doing it I
didn't get so lucky but hey I know I get
it man you're not the first to say that
people don't realize is every actor from
what I'm not an actor but every actor I
talk to you talks about how they have a
different process some people have like
a pre shooting ritual or they like quiet
or they're like music each of you
obviously must work in an individual way
what what what surprised you about each
other and like the way you like to work
I really dug working with Taylor again
we just had a lot of moments where you
know we were either like in solidarity
just together mm-hmm just having to be
okay with each other's company
and so you know and so yeah I'd really
bug it yes same I think it depends on
the scene obviously but the shootout
stuff you you know obviously safety and
whatnot you're you are handling weapons
so it's like that's the focus on those
nights of just being safe and smart
about it and not trying to like improv
kills yeah and muzzle awareness and all
that kind of stuff but then the real
scenes it's just you know making sure
you're getting and reaching the full
potential working with Kirk really
closely and vibing and seeing where it
goes you know and being open to if you
improv go off the page or whatnot I love
that stuff so I think that's why we work
so well together
did either you keep the bandanas yeah I
wear it probably every other night I
wore mine here and they said I couldn't
do it join me in every or so they're
actually like I mean they're they're
tough looking they're cool bandanas you
would hope I mean you don't want like
Care Bear bandana when you're doing or
do you maybe that's maybe it's a little
more tweaked out if you dare that's a
good point uh it would have been pretty
funny I really enjoyed the shootout in
the what's his name they could be I
forget the actor's name but the
launderer guy yeah yeah scene is like
brutal and right from the door right on
in can you sort of talk a little bit
about shooting that scene [ __ ] five
six days and I was
it was a lot of moving parts to it but
it was set up you know we got to we got
to do some choreography yeah and we got
some good training and I think to help
me yeah look legit we got to go down was
it Brooklyn Brewery
yeah Brooklyn training with SWAT
training with NYPD down there you know
just helping everything look legit and
feel the JIT and obviously be be safe
and I love that it is it's not a stage
that's someone's apartment right you
know so it's really grounded and rooted
in just reality and to have these cops
with us being like all right you're not
gonna go there for cover let's try and
make this work and keep it grounded so
it's very technical which just takes
five plus days to do I know five minutes
that's what I was going to say though a
lot of people who watch the movies we
watch movies or TV or whatever they
really don't know what it takes to make
an action set piece what well well that
too yes yeah but unlike a movie actions
enemies it requires talk a little about
the the stamina it takes to really keep
that energy going over that time I mean
you saw me running yeah talk about
stamina yeah I mean I haven't run that
much since I was playing Jesse Owens you
know is like a bitter go so yeah
definitely definitely stamina especially
when you're shooting all nights and
you're having to like pull energy from
places you didn't know existed you know
just to just to get it through so and
the stakes are high high high right so
there are a thousand so I think that's
the energy where you're expelling so in
between takes I I think both of us just
take a beat and just hoard it for the
next take so that's really what we're
doing and just rehearsing with with the
stun teas and the cops and seeing if
Kirk and what he wants to do if I'm not
mistaken you've been talking for a while
about directing a feature yeah what's
the status um I just got another job so
that's on hold
hopefully late next year we'll see
I was gonna say that's first rule
problems yes very much
you know first world oh yeah before I
run at a time I've been asking everyone
a few fun questions yeah what TV show
would you love to guest star on ooh v
fleabag what movie have you seen the
most mmm slap shot an explorer or Butch
Cassidy okay I would say the Lion King
yes classic do you have a favorite ride
at Disneyland never been to Disneyland
I'm scared of heights
come on you lied really I'm serious can
you do this like the soft ride I still
don't know if he's serious I mean you
know that really ups the teeth it's just
right there for me right who's right
there for me I think that's his tipping
point uh no pun intended
what was the last thing I think I got a
rap button last thing now what was the
last thing you were obsessed with
whether it be a book a movie my mirror
that's that's a good one right yeah I
don't even think I could Tommy I'll
leave it there on that note you guys
have a fantastic day thank you so much
for your time yeah good to see you man